Donald Trump is increasingly at odds with
America in terms of the protests.
And Donald Trump is increasingly at odds with
his own officials.
We'll talk about the America part a little
bit later.
But let's start here.
As you know, Donald Trump has been considering
use of the Insurrection Act of 18 07 to send
U.S. military to states to quell protests.
And in fact, there were some troops deployed
yesterday.
But reportedly they were very quickly called
back by the Pentagon.
Still early reporting on that.
But there seems to be a conflict brewing between
Donald Trump and the Pentagon there.
Now, this barely warrants repeating for you
guys, but I will repeat it anyway.
The protests are mostly peaceful.
They are also increasingly peaceful.
With every passing day, we see protesters
policing themselves more and more, rooting
out people who want to cause trouble.
And that's a very good thing to see.
Well, Donald Trump is thinking about could
we maybe send tanks to the streets to intimidate
people?
And the Pentagon, to their credit, seems to
be not having.
Secretary of Defense Mark Esper has increasingly
distanced himself from Trump's ideas on this.
We don't know whether Espera will be fired
within 48 hours.
That may well be.
But over the last two days, Mark Esper has
been saying, you know, my comments on Monday
and Tuesday.
They were mostly just general shows of support
for Donald Trump, you know, telling governors
request military aid if you need it.
But Asper reportedly didn't really think Trump
was going to act on militarizing the streets
against governors demands.
This is a huge mistake by Mark Esper.
Mark Esper underestimated the erratic and
dangerous nature of Donald Trump's out-of-control
authoritarianism.
What we are learning and what every Trump
official should know by now is that it's very
dangerous to play Kate.
Donald Trump with the.
Oh, yes, Mr. President.
The military.
Yes, sure, Mr. President.
Of course.
Because now Trump is actually asking, hey,
what kind of tanks could we maybe send to
the streets of America?
According to what a Pentagon official told
The Daily Beast and the Pentagon.
Listen, the Pentagon is not the good guy in
the history of American politics and geopolitics.
There's no doubt about that.
But the Pentagon seems to be making it clear
they're not looking to send in the military
and they're not looking to send in tanks.
And once again, I would not be shocked if
Secretary of Defense Mark Esper was fired
within the next couple of days.
I said this earlier and it bears repeating.
This is not a rehearsal.
Donald Trump is not distinguishing between
protesters and looters.
Donald Trump had protesters smoked out to
clear a path so that he could take a picture
with a Bible in front of a church.
A few days ago, and I want to point out something
else.
A lot of either ignorant people or bad faith
actors.
You can never really tell with some of these
people.
They are trying to conflate the state National
Guard with Trump sending in federal troops.
And I really want to make clear that there
is a big difference here.
National Guards are run by states governors,
for example, a couple of months ago brought
out their respective state National Guards
for corona virus related help.
They've also brought out their state National
Guards around the protests.
That is completely different than the president
saying.
I don't agree with how governors are handling
this.
I'm going to deploy U.S. military to states
against the wishes of governors by utilizing
the Insurrection Act of 18.
That is a completely insidious authoritarian
threat.
The state governors saying we just need support
from our state National Guard.
That's how it's supposed to work, that states
rights and we shouldn't conflate it.
We can still be against the deployment of
state National Guards, but don't allow yourself
to be tricked into thinking if a state is
deploying the National Guard.
There's really no difference with Trump sending
in the troops.
It is very, very different now as far as Donald
Trump and his tanks.
Trump has been desperate for tanks rolling
on American streets since he became president
of the United States.
Remember, for a while he wanted a parade with
tanks.
He wanted it to happen for propaganda reasons.
Now, Trump wants tanks out there to repress
protesters.
He just wants tanks out there at his say.
So that's really what it comes to.
He wants.
I don't know if it's his own version of version
of Tiananmen Square or if Trump believes that
the strength that will be portrayed by tanks
rolling at his say so we'll reflect positively
on him.
I don't know exactly what Trump is thinking,
but this is all authoritarian dystopia.
Protests repress them with the military tanks,
roll them down American streets.
And by the by the way, I mean, this is like
so minor given what's going on.
Rolling tanks down American streets is extremely
damaging to the streets, to the roads in a
physical sense.
I don't know if Trump knows that, but tanks
are not meant to be rolling down American
streets or better said, streets are not meant
to handle the weight and characteristics of
tanks.
And you know who's going to repair that?
Is Trump going to pay for that?
Trump keeps talking about doing infrastructure
spending and we're still not doing it, just
like a minor coda to the broader story that
we're dealing with here.
We're going to have more on this, a lot more,
in fact, on The David Pakman Show Instagram
page, David Pakman show.
Make sure you're following us there.
Coming up next, Trump's former secretary of
defense, Jim Mattis, denounces Trump, calls
him a threat to the Constitution.
And Trump responds predictably.
Let me put it that way.
We'll talk about that next.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.